Very Pale flesh again.
So we watched Netflix is new death note
movie this weekend and thought it
merited some discussion.
And of course some spoilers.
If you watched our video on the death
note anime a couple of weeks ago,
you know that we're big fans of the
show,
draws out incredibly nuanced ideas about
the nature of justice,
justice,
and even participates in it's own
philosophical dialogue throughout the
series.
It's just damn good television,
the movie.
Well,
it's not exactly good cinema.
Now,
off the bat,
I just want to say that adapting at 37
episode animate to a single movie is
really,
really hard.
If someone hired me to do that,
I'd be in my pants.
So we're not here to grade how closely
the new film sticks to the anime or the
Monga.
It's an adaptation and it deserves some
room to do its own thing.
So let's look at the film on its own
terms.
It's definitely got some good things
going for it.
And the thing that I most admire is its
attempt to preserve some of the thematic
richness of the anime,
which is an impressive goal for a 100
minute movie that already packs in a lot
action sequences,
detective games,
Gore and teen romance from lights
argument that his systematic cheating is
no big deal.
I'm looking at homework here for at
least 15 different students.
All right,
I get it.
I'm in trouble.
All I'm trying to say is you have the
chance to stop the type of people who
make things hard for everybody.
You've got to see the big picture here
to his conversation with his dad at the
end.
Death note tries to put some moral
ambiguity into lights,
character,
and gesture to bigger questions about
the nature of good and evil.
Given the time constraints.
He was smart not to attempt the massive
discourses on justice that we see in the
anime,
but the film makes clear that it's still
interested in ethics just in a
simplified form.
Exactly.
Can I do with this death now and see
what happens?
Unfortunately,
that's where the film gets itself into
trouble.
Toward the beginning.
Mr.
Turner tells light guns is only as good
as the Jameson I make sure people can
trust are here.
Of course,
he's talking about the role of the
Seattle police,
but light seems to adopt a similar
principle using the power of the death
note.
He liked his animate counterpart wants
to create a new world where innocent
civilians are protected from the people
who make life miserable.
The death note is his gun and that's the
aim.
Although he gets squeamish about
offering some law enforcement,
we never really see light compromising
the intentions behind that aim until his
David Copperfield reveal at the end of
the film.
Instead they bring in a seductive power
hungry girlfriend to play the role of
bad cop.
For 90% of the movie light is
unambiguously the good guy,
or at least be kind of okay guy and
that's a problem.
Kira largely had the support of the
people including the police until the
death of the FBI team and who sent eight
federal agents walking off a building.
The duplicitous mia who stole the
notebook from light and wrote his name
in it,
bad,
bad me.
Who killed what tare by not burning the
page with his name on it.
We're clearly supposed to blame me up
even though light put it there in the
first place.
Although the film spends next to no time
developing what light wants out of his
new world,
he's still shockingly quick to abandon
and once someone dies who hasn't
committed a felony or stolen someone's
lunch money,
you really think people are going to be
on their needs.
If you can talk to her like that.
We're not killing my dad mia.
This is overview just we're not the good
guys anymore.
We aren't the good guys anymore.
Sounds a lot more like people don't like
us.
Then an actual statement about cure is
morality of rule and while the third act
of the film tries to play up,
the difference between lights,
reluctance to kill people and bad meals
bloodthirstiness lights,
shifts seems more pragmatic than
anything.
Lights change of perspective isn't an
indication that there was ever problems
with his plan for becoming a God.
Just that the circumstances have changed
and he doesn't really want to go to
prison,
but mia doesn't really mind if a gun is
only as good as its aim.
It seems like the film should be asking
questions about lights,
aim with the death note,
but instead of saying be careful of
aiming your gun in this direction,
it's more make sure your crazy
girlfriend doesn't get ahold of your
gun.
Okay.
L's quick personality flip from,
I don't kill,
I just bring justice to I might kill you
in the same way you killed hundreds of
people seems to be totally dependent on
circumstance.
The detective strong moral framework
developed since childhood gets tossed
away instantly when his friend goes
missing,
but there's no emphasis on the
significance of that change.
Light ends the film by telling his dad,
first I was just going to kill all the
bad guys and good guys.
Sometimes you got to choose the lesser
of the two years,
but what are these two evils?
My guess is that not even light notes,
unlike the animate.
I know,
sorry,
I had to say it.
Death notes.
Ethical ambiguity is less about opening
a multitude of possibilities and more
about shrugging in the direction of good
and evil while ultimately saying nothing
interesting.
Now,
once again,
condensing an animate of that magnitude
into a relatively short film is a
difficult task and I won't begrudge the
filmmakers some reductions in depth,
but what the story clone to most
hutchins about good and evil was poorly
executed and ended up hamstringing its
potential both philosophically and
dramatically.
Anyway,
those are our thoughts.
We're still experimenting with this new
quick take format,
so if you have thoughts on what we
should cover next,
let us know these guys.
If you're looking for more wise crack
quick takes on the latest,
be sure to check out our rick and Morty
podcasts,
the squatch where we break down every
single new episode and you could find
all this in the description to catch you
all next time.